you don't say squeeze aujourd'hui en
soit on est lundi exclusive soir une
nouvelle vidéo en fait là je reviens de
trois jours à londres avec gwen voilà
c'était super et c'est parce qu'en fait
elle faisait un an et demi qu'on n'était
pas parti quelque part qu'on n'était pas
sorti du quotidien et en fait je fais
cette vidéo pour vous dire que j'ai
réalisé plein de trucs en fait là bas
souvent ces gens partent en vacances
même quelques jours ou parfois même
quelques semaines pour ses très longues
vacances c'est pour sortir du quotidien
pour se changer les idées
changer leurs habitudes et c est ça fait
beaucoup de bien boostés que trois jours
mais ça fait du bien aussi mais je me
suis rendu compte que en fait j'ai de la
chance mais à mort
la mesure ne compte que bath j'adore ce
que je fais en fait ce quotidien m'a
manqué quelques pas en fait je me suis
dit bon le matin je me lève et je me
disais ah qu'est-ce que je vais pas
faire comme vidéo banon raconte lucas
calme-toi je veux dire je sais pas j'ai
réalisé que que j'ai une chance énorme
de faire ce que je fais de vivre de ça 2
quand je me lève le matin je suis
content de faire ce que je fais je suis
pas par exemple je travaille pas au un
endroit qui me plaît pas je me lève pas
de mauvais perdants ont fait chier faut
aller travailler
moi je fais mes délires avec vous et je
me disais en fait même la page 12 et
[ __ ] mais c'est vrai que des fois il
me manque ces gens c'est marrant parce
que finalement on se connaît pas
personnellement
bon je vois certaines trouvent sur
twitter vos photos vos pseudos ce même
panneau nom et prénom et je me dis
[ __ ] mais ces personnes que finalement
je connais pas énormément vous
connaissez le plus que je vous connais
finalement et jeudi mais même moment que
ça manque de passer un bon moment avec
eux je sais pas de jouer un jeu avec eux
parce qu'en fait quand je fais une vidéo
j'ai pas l'impression que vous êtes un
million à me regarder jouer comme ça où
1500 milles ou de formules j'en sais
rien mais l'impression que toi qui
regarde cette vidéo tu es avec moi sur
ce siège tous vers la par exemple c'est
juste là et puis que bonjour jai
ensemble qu'on s'amuse comme on a tous
fait en fait dans notre vie joue avec
nos potes un jeu même s'il y en a qu à
la manette puisque c'est un jeu en solo
on peut ce niveau peut vraiment se
marrer devant et bah moi ça me manque et
voilà je me disais [ __ ] mais en fait
je gère mon quotidien
beaucoup de gens fuient un peu leur
quotidien mais moi j'adore mon quotidien
et c'est grâce à vous et en fait je me
dis que des fois on vous remercie pas à
ses fins moi personnellement du cas je
trouve que je vous remercie pas assez
pour ce mouvement porté en fait la vidéo
qu'on a fait hier là on regarde mes sens
et une vidéo machin ou c'est assez
marrant de voir un mec tout jeunes tous
points ses les fesses faire des vidéos
mais au final beaucoup j'en passe par là
en fait en réalité
juste que c'est drôle après coup
quelques années après quand ils voient
comment ttc comme les musiciens
devraient commencer à faire de la
musique je pense pas que le mec fait un
tube du premier coup et il fait des
trucs pourris baba pourri mais bon il
fait ce qu'il peut et puis finalement
ils évoluent ils progressent et nous ça
a été un peu pareil et je me suis dit
[ __ ] mais qu'est ce qu'on a fait du
chemin dans mes premières vidéos quand
j'étais en en seconde à l'époque que je
savais pas quelle voie prendre d'arriver
en première ou en terminale que je fais
à manger poste je lui avais dit mais
j'avais essayé de faire un un btm non
oui un bts cadreur monteur un truc comme
ça et tu disais qu'au public m'avait
recalés bien sévèrement pourtant que
j'ai mon bac et bac s mais je me suis
dit bon ok très bien ça marche eh ben je
vais faire des vidéos et ça va me plaire
voilà écouter les gens qui te regardent
autour quoi faire des vidéos sur
internet
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça pas les
parents surtout bien évidemment les
jeunes font un stylet et comme j'ai dis
maintenant tout le matin quand je me
lève je me dis que pas que je vais
bosser mais que je vais m'amuser
bagis service du travail mais bon c'est
vraiment de l'amusement et que je peux
vivre de ça et à côté je vois des pots
tout même mon frère ou quoi qui eux sont
dans un dans un cadre plus standard puis
je voulais juste vous remercier encore
une fois pour ça que partir loin dit de
mon quotidien m'a fait prendre
conscience d'à quel point j étais bien
en fait et c'est ça des fois on se rend
pas compte de certaines choses
j'ai aussi pris conscience d'une chose
c'est qu'il faut à tout prix prendre
plaisir dans ce que l'on fait c'est à
dire que si beaucoup de gens veulent une
vidéo sur telle ou telle chose mais qu'
on n'a pas attendu que ça de la fère et
ben faut pas la faire et si l inverse on
a vraiment envie de faire une vidéo mais
qu'on sait que ça va pas plus plaire que
ça aux gens au final on pense qu'il n'a
pas pu se faire que ça aux gens il faut
quand même la faire et se faire plaisir
avant toute chose pour garder lé envie
de faire des vidéos gardez-les envie de
créer du contenu sur youtube voilà il
faut pas garde cette envie et c'est ça
que je veux vous faire comprendre c'est
pour ça que des fois je fais certains
trucs que des gens n'aiment pas par
exemple et vidéo à plusieurs je sais
qu'il ya pas mal de gens qui adorent
complètement et d'autres qui détestent
au plus haut point mais c'est juste que
c'est des vidéos qu'ils me changent au
ciel que je fais d'habitude
et puis qui me permettent de mettre mes
amis mon entourage dans ce monde dans
lequel je suis toute l'année presque
tous les jours etc etc des vidéos qui me
plaisent énormément donc j'ai fait quand
même même s'il ya des gens qui font au
c'est chiant je raconte des sols etc et
jade pas dire et c'est très énervant au
pelage et puis c'est une chance ne faut
pas l'oublier c'est
[ __ ] de chance de vivre de ça j'ai pas
en france il ya peut-être 30 youtuber 42
grand max qui vivent de ça et je fais
partie de ceux là et c'est un truc de
fou et c'est grâce à vous et voilà je
sais pas dans le train sur le retour de
londres réalisé tous âges écouter des
musiques un petit peu triste et
sournoise et je le disais bon t'as vu
que tu as de la chance tu as vraiment de
la chance c'est un truc de dingue quand
tu vois les gens galèrent autour fin je
me répète mais c'est une chance
incroyable et je me suis dit si toi car
cette vidéo qui délire avec moi sur les
jeux ou même sur les sketchs etc tu as
des envies dans la vie des des trucs que
tu veux faire
bon faut que ce soit un petit peu sensé
quand même mais franchement foncé si
vous voulez faire des vidéos par exemple
sur youtube il faut pas attendre quelque
chose de ça il faut pas se dire je fais
des vidéos dans le but d'être connus ou
je sais pas trop quoi je sais pas quelle
autre et zou un peu bizarres des fois
les gens trouvent à faire des vidéos
il faut juste se dire c'est un délire
que j'aime ça me plaît de créer ces
choses voilà je le fais on verra comment
ça se passe mais allez-y n'ayez pas peur
parce que j'ai actuellement on est un
peu dans un monde où on se moque assez
facilement c'est plus c'est plus cool de
dire aura ta vu cette personne là est
ridicule
oc news qui fait alors on va rigoler sur
sa tronche que de dire oh j'adore ce que
cette personne la fessée coup ce qu'elle
fait regard va voir tout aussi j'aime
bien et je sais que des fois ça crée des
sortes de barrières les gens ils n'osent
pas faire le pas vers vers ce qu'ils ont
envers ce qu'ils ont envie de faire au
fond des par exemple chez gap 1 du
rythme de faire des vidéos qui ne vont
pas les faire parce que ils sont pris
2,3 critique dans la tronche jorane et
ucopia un tel homme tu fais ça comme lui
mâche un pull assez nul n'a jamais
franchement hier soir j'ai vu brio que
je faisais vous avez vu ce que c'était
je dis pas que quand vous en faisant des
vidéos vous allez forcément bien marché
sur youtube etc
mais si vous y prenez du plaisir et que
c'est une petite passion que vous avez
et bien foncé et fait le trouvez votre
passion on a tous au fond peut-être une
passion un peu moi par exemple c'était
les vidéos et les jeux vidéo mais il y a
voilà ça fait du bien des fois qu'on est
dans le quotidien qu'on n'y est pas
forcément bien de se plonger dans
quelque chose moi ça a été les vidéos à
l'époque voilà pour ceux qui sont pas
forcément très à l'aise dans leur vie et
qui à l'école ça va pas forcément bien
que qui sont victimes de moqueries ou
quoi moi personnellement je déteste ça
voilà voir quelqu'un qui qui
je prends des moqueries à longueur de
journée toute l'année je déteste ça bon
là je parle je passe d'un sujet à un
autre comme ça sans 36 ans a fait un peu
bizarre mais voilà c'est je veux dire si
vous n'êtes pas très très bien dans
votre quotidien
essayez de trouver des choses auxquelles
vous investir créer des choses
voilà c'est juste tout ce que j'ai à
dire parce que moi ça m'a un peu sauvé
de l'époque où j'étais très très mal
dans ma tête mentalement me fait de
faire des vidéos c'était un peu ce qui
me faisait tenir
donc voilà j'espère que vous aussi vous
trouverez un petit truc qui vous fera
tenir enfin bon voilà je vois là je fais
juste cette vidéo pour vous dire pour
vous dire merci encore une fois ça m'a
fait bizarre de faire cette petite vidéo
parce que c'est vrai que finalement je
peux pas vous parler directement comme
ça pendant cinq dix minutes dehors
s'intéresse peut-être pas du tout les
9/10 d'entre vous mais au moins j'aurais
mis la vidéo que je voulais mettre où je
vois où je vous dis ça je tenais
vraiment à vous dire ces choses là
et puis et puis voilà merci pour tout je
suis tout ému décidément en ce moment
c'est squeeze lui
j'espère que ça vous aura fait plaisir
aussi que ça vous aura donné du courage
pour ceux qui sont pas extrêmement bien
de leur quotidien et qui pour ceux qui
sont bien et ben j'espère que vous le
serez encore mieux voilà merci à vous
regarder cette vidéo les jeunes regarder
mais mes vidéos tous les jours semaines
à années à venir c'est super cool
et puis j'espère que tout ça ça
continuera encore longtemps merci
beaucoup où tu as tout le monde
pis